what is the worst thing about rebel well
the worst thing about Rand Paul is his
arrogance he is allergic to the idea
that inconsistency is okay he refuses to
admit that his positions have changed to
an absurd degree he is extremely
confident in his own views on and just
to the point where it comes off as he's
arrogant he knows that all the problems
you look at him and he looks too young
to know all that much you can't you
can't do that you have to kind of knew
the doctor book about her he's a he he's
a doctor he's smart uh but you know he
uh and he's smart guy um but being a
smart guy being a smart politician of
two different things he's very new still
to this game of being a national
political figure and his arrogance just
really really rubs people the wrong way
at times and not just not just the media
but it comes off looking and as if he's
dogmatic the last thing you want in a
libertarian candidate is to appear
dogmatic yeah is that the catch-22 with
Rand Paul that he's a libertarian but
obviously has to take some positions
that the party wants him to take so on
something like foreign policy where he
always before he was running was always
about bringing America back you know
cutting foreign aid to all countries
where now he's hedging it a little bit
and now it's good it sounds like it's
going to be a little bit more robust but
that doesn't to me it doesn't seem like
that's going to be enough for the
Republicans to really get around him you
know probably not i mean on issues he
doesn't really care about and that's
probably one of them he can change his
position all he wants the problem and no
one will really care because frankly
they shouldn't I mean issues you care
about you're going to be strong and
consistent on the positions you aren't
they can kind of they can kind of sway
but you have to understand and have some
self-awareness of your of your evolution
as a person or at least not events this
I am holier than now I know it all I and
you know I'm you know I'm a doctor who
is sort of a you know new to this game
but I know everything in the world and
you've got to listen to me and you know
sir to do serve dirt surgery yeah it
rubs people
just rub people the wrong way and I'm
just talking the elite media yeah I'm
frankly they like that because it
provides really good viral video but his
certitude and his again this allergic
this allergy has to being called
inconsistent which everyone is
inconsistent but he reacts it's this
thing this trigger thing that sets him
off and it makes it look really
unattractive as a candidate and I think
it's the worst